the reaction American first action
senior adviser Sean Spicer the author of
the book still winning foxnews
contributed charlie hurt you know you're
both laughing by the way Sean fight what
are you doing going on that stupid dance
show what are you thinking why would you
do that I mean I admire the courage to
vote there Sean you need my vote I'm
gonna have some fun for goodness sake
show these people know people we can I
want to have some fun it's about time
that enjoyed myself and and have a show
that I can courage my kids to watch run
myself have some fun it listen you you
take it a lot of crap I take it every
day charlie takes a lot you're in the
wrong business if you can't take a
little baby bedbug tap you Rhett you
don't belong you know offering your
commentary people I know you have these
young warriors that are naked in their
basement they're just firing out one
shot after another take it well III
think that if that's the worst thing
that he's been called my goodness take a
look at my Twitter feed any day I
welcome because of that [ __ ] other
people will share it with me but I'll
tell you the thing that's so interesting
about this is that these guys can't take
a punch and III agree with Brett in the
stand point out that I don't think that
we should be using the kind of language
but it's amazing when the folks on the
left and and those nevertrump errs that
claim to be from the right go out and
demonize everyone who supports this
president look the fact the matter is
this president got 306 electoral votes
he won states like Michigan Pennsylvania
Wisconsin instead of demonizing us
instead of trying to ostracize us they
might want to learn from us because do
you point out there's a lot of
hard-working men and women out there
that read that the president's message
resonated with it's about time we
started listening to these people more
instead of trying to push them further
and further away charlie one of the
things I admired most about the
president he gets hit harder than
anybody I've ever seen in politics any
fights back and he doesn't stop it
and they can really yeah and and he
never gives up it's amazing I don't know
where the guy gets the energy to do that
but watching those clips that you showed
I felt like I was watching a scene out
of One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest I
mean these people they have lost their
minds they're there legitimately but
have become completely mentally unhinged
and I think for them you know the idea
that President Trump won in 2016 is
absolutely that they still haven't
gotten or you know gotten their brains
around that and then the fact that two
and a half years later he's still
winning on a daily basis he's racking up
huge accomplishments and all of the
regular normal America is finding things
to compliment about him and these people
they cannot stand it Oh irredeemable
deplorable you know II Walmart people
cling to God guns Bibles religion I'll
take it
nah man take all of it I want to hang
out with those people I'm never going on
Washington Carson on dance I can't now
in my contract I don't have to go done I
quote they won't even ask yeah I don't
see nothing Gary here all right thank
you both